[Music]
mute findings is a powerful volume
management tool within security command
center it allows you to automatically
silence findings based on criteria you
specify or manually silence individual
findings
this feature is relevant for many
potential use cases for example assets
within non-production environments where
some stricter requirements may not be
applicable
recommendations to use customer managed
encryption keys in projects that don't
contain critical data
when granting broad access on a data
store which intentionally is open to the
public and disseminates public
information
or for findings not relevant to your
organization based on your company's
policies
muted findings don't appear by default
in the security command center dashboard
however they continue to be logged and
can be accessed as needed
there are two ways you can mute findings
you can create mute rules that
automatically mute findings as they are
generated
or you can choose to mute and unmute
individual findings
let's see this feature in action
currently we are located at the security
command center findings tab for a
specific project
we'll focus on a category of findings
that are generated when bucket logging
is disabled suppose we want to silence
findings within this category we can use
the mute findings feature to hide them
as you can see we can select individual
findings to mute and unmute using the
mute options menu but you can also
create a mute rule to automatically mute
findings as they are generated based on
a criteria
first we'll give the mute role in id
note that this rule will apply to all
findings generated within the resource
that we have selected
now we'll set up the filter by selecting
category equal to bucket logging
disabled
after clicking apply we can preview any
existing findings that match this filter
once this rule is implemented all
existing and new findings that exactly
match the filter will be hidden and the
mute attribute for the findings will be
set to muted
one thing to note if you are creating
mute rules with the gcloud tool or
security command center api muting
existing and future findings are two
separate operations
so be sure to check out the
documentation for details
after clicking save we'll return to the
security command center and review our
findings
our new mute role has taken effect and
we can no longer see any findings in the
bucket logging disabled category
as mentioned mute rules created in the
console will mute both existing and
future findings that match the filter so
let's create another bucket to see how
future findings are handled
we're back after creating a new bucket
we can see that no additional findings
in the bucket logging disabled category
are visible however findings that are
muted are not deleted and new findings
that match mute rules continue to be
logged as such they can be viewed by
selecting more options and choosing
include muted findings
now we can see the muted findings
including the additional finding that
was just created for our new bucket
the include muted findings option is
useful when you are trying to review all
findings for any audit or compliance
needs
now if we would like to review only the
muted findings we can apply a filter
mute equals muted
in these muted findings we can see when
a finding was muted and who muted the
finding which we can use for audit
purposes at any time we can also
configure any notifications that we've
set up to exclude updates from any new
or existing findings that are muted
mute rules can be managed from the mute
settings page
on this page we can view our rules edit
them and delete them
when we delete a rule it doesn't unmute
any findings that were muted in the past
as a result of this rule but future
findings will no longer be muted
congratulations you're now equipped to
use the mute findings feature and
security command center as a
customizable volume management tool
[Music]
you